[Music]
behind every Wonder Woman costume is a
powerful one and behind every powerful
woman and hunger for Chuck and I too
much fun our spring thank you
Isis Felicia there you go first let me
change thank you very much up
we're a it's wonderful yeah you should
be very proud
thank you very much you should be very
proud two stores two Sundays what
delicious fight for heat I'm Tiana a
droid and this is the Wonder Woman ice
cream battle following a June 2017
release
DC's Wonder Woman proved to be an
instant hit shattering box-office
records and the glass ceiling but who
scoops the best sundae celebrating her
success Cold Stone Creamery and their
Wonder Woman very bold ice cream or
Pinkberry
and their Wonder Woman power berry
frozen yogurt in the name of truth
justice and desserts we decided to find
out
first we hit the cold stone x squared
test out their trees the very bold ice
cream is made with dark chocolate triple
berry ice cream chocolate shavings
raspberries and top gold glitter that
shines brighter than the lasso of truth
the crunchy chocolate shavings and
super-rich ice cream combined to create
my own personal crypt
that's
next we head to Pinkberry to see how
their Wonder Woman power bearing frozen
yokel DUP and SAP it's made for NOLA
raspberries and dark chocolate bins all
folded into a sweet mixed berry for his
yogurt the chocolate bits add a perfect
crunch and the healthy granola made me
feel super charged and ready to balance
rainy and that the outside but I smell
feel powerful with my wonderful husband
so is proved to be the most powerful
cold stones Wonder Woman very bold ice
cream definitely saved the day sweet
raspberries and crunchy chocolate
shavings combined with perfectly creamy
dark chocolate ice cream was a force
that couldn't be beat life is super here
is but a delicious scoop of ice cream
pretty